des aliments s'est fabriqué ada de
ressources locales c'est
[Musique]
mon papa d'abord il est ingénieur
agronome et il nous a très peu introduit
à la crème aux travaux champêtres
quelquefois luc malet dans sa ferme avec
lui et c'est quelqu'un qui nous a
beaucoup encouragés qui nous encourage
d'ailleurs beaucoup pour les et 8
les problèmes alimentaires mondiaux ont
été largement discutée et
j ai su qu aucun changement climatique
ont été lâchement discuté dernièrement
lors de la cop16 et on se rend compte on
a de graves problèmes alimenté en
afrique les enfants sont mal métriques
déjà à l'âge de sevrage ils n'ont pas
assez à l'alimentation de complément
approprié pour le h est un âge scolaire
ou un âge préscolaire ils sont exposés à
des snacks ce qu'ils sont riches en
sucre riches en matières grasses qui ne
sont pas forcément bon pour l'heure
alors mon sujet de recherches actuelles
portent sur l'utilisation de ressources
locales résilience au clean changement
climatique tels que le mille pour
formuler des snacks ce est rude et est
rude et c'est quoi c'est une technologie
qu'on utilise une technologie assez
simple qui permet de cuire avant
températures hautes pressions pour
donner des produits directement
consommables j'utilise le mille la peau
de pub le baobab et de la farine de bois
afin de formuler d'avoir une formulation
nutritionnellement intéressante pour ses
enfants
on observe tout autour de moi j'ai
remarqué qu'ils avaient quand même des
problèmes parce que les producteurs
agricoles n'avaient pas forcément de
moyens de conservation de leur
production ce qui fait qu'ils pètent
beaucoup de denrées
dans les champs ou parfois après la
récolte il fallait trouver des solutions
pour la considération
à long terme je dirais c'est d'avoir des
aliments des snacks ce
fabriqués localement avec des ressources
locales nutritionnellement c'est pour
les enfants sur le marché local et ça
pour après m'être peut-être d'insérer
cette nappe pourquoi pas dans les
programmes de cantines scolaires afin
que les enfants puissent les utiliser
comme aliment de tous les jours
actuellement en n1 à l'étape de
recherche encore on en est pas encore à
l'étape de commercialisation pour passer
à l'étape il faudra vraiment que la
populaire que ce soit bien au niveau
recherchent que la richesse à affiner
que le produit fini soit bon
je pense qu'aujourd'hui la place de la
femme dans toute la société est
indéniable est ce que la fondation le
real fait pour permettre de promouvoir
les femmes scientifiques c'est
extrêmement important ça le paiement de
jouer de rôle modèle pour les futures
générations et de france puis un réseau
intéressant de femmes qui pourront
s'entraider pour évoluer dans leur
carrière contribuer au développement de
leur pays